[Music]
welcome to the United States of America
if you conduct yourself well you can
consider us friends so Mike I know
you've been playing a lot of civics over
the just past few months but now it
turns out that you've you've got your
hands on basically a full version of the
game and have played you've done a
complete playthrough start to finish
first of all who did you play heads and
did you win I play it as Norway and yes
I did win through a military victory
which is kind of the most boring in my
opinion but it was still really fun
because of the changes tip six made and
it was you know like I actually you know
four axes kind of pretty much gave us
access to the full game - like different
difficulties I played on Prince
difficulty which is like default and we
only had ten of the civilizations of the
twenty it's for all intensive purposes
it was the full game but I got to
actually see how civics works over you
know like more than just 150 turns yeah
gotcha so how did playing a full
playthrough compared to playing just the
first hundred fifty turns it is very
very different than sieve five uh
something that's plagued sieve games and
a lot of turn-based or like forex games
since they have become a thing is the
mid game turns are out can be boring
right you know you have your first
hundred fifty turns where you're you
know you're building new cities you're
expanding your civilization you're
trying to figure out what course you
want to plot and then the mid game terms
we're usually those ones where you're
kind of just like hunkering down getting
the right luxury resources trying to
like establish trade routes from maybe
taking a few cities if you're like
militarily inclined then the late-game
turns are like you know the Rushford the
different kinds of victories right yeah
I'm Christian know right before
everything kind of comes to a head at
the very end sure it kind of like
culminates and you see whose plan worked
and who's didn't in Civ six from at
least from this playthrough the mid-game
terms were actually really fun
I haven't played more than one full
playthrough and I'm really eager to
because from what I've seen sip six is
kind of challenging me more than any
other Civ has and it's also making me
pivot more so I set out assuming I would
do a victory you know like a military
victory but then those mid game turns
with active research which kind like
this side quest system that we talked
about before that pushes your pulls you
in one way on the science tree
regardless of what your plan might be
kind of you know makes you reconsider
what you're doing and what direction
you're taking these mid game terms
really actually kind of felt just as
suspenseful as the beginning in the end
interesting in part because of the
active research like that was the main
thing kind of fueling those pivots it
was a combination of the active research
and then the other leaders also like you
know sieve is always kind of like in its
marketing said the we want the leaders
to be personalities with a rising tide
the expansion to beyond or if they
really tried to push that yeah but now
leaders have these historical agendas
that kind of match up with as you would
assume history so you'd like Teddy
Roosevelt you know speak softly carry a
big stick he'll threaten you a lot and
he's not afraid to actually start
fighting you and then you have like the
Vikings like I played are very like
naval inclined and then like they're one
of their bonuses is that um you can
invade the coastline with a naval unit
you can pillage farms with a one less
action and then you can attack people an
extra attack count and they're not
they're very defensive but they're very
good at expanding and as you would
assume like Vikings back in the day
they're very kind of you know aggressive
and the other leaders kind of like if
they had these historical agendas but
they also had the hidden agendas which
is what you start trying to figure out
as you're going you've spies in other
cities you have alliances with different
leaders it'll say oh you know like Teddy
Roosevelt is like building a lot of
spies so you're like okay so maybe he's
kind of going for a cultural victory
because he's trying to kidnap or steal
my great lead great people or you know
like this person's building up their
military suit like okay maybe their
hidden agendas actually till just
launched out like a full-on assault so I
kind of like started the mid-game terms
trying to figure out the other leaders
and from this playthrough it really felt
like four X's might have nailed that
this time or at least from this
playthrough maybe I was just imagining
things and making it was make me
paranoid which is also pretty cool it
may have been in your head but yeah you
know that's true that is still pretty
cool chair it's something to hear that
there was such like a noticeable
mechanical impact that the different
civilizations weren't just flavor this
time around mean that that has always
been kind of an emphasis for them but I
don't know if they've ever really kind
of hit that so I'm happy to hear that
that was more tangible in your
playthrough this time how did the
unstack Cities play in like a full
playthrough versus 150 turns because
that's been a big thing for them a big
change that cities you're now spread out
you really have to pay a little more
attention to what you're putting in a
particular city and how you lay those
cities out so yeah over the course of a
long full game
how did that work right so it's always
easy for us to say like these unsex
cities make you really think ahead and
kind of like consider the map in new
ways but it really did in this
playthrough it made me realize how much
I did not think ahead
you know you establish like a university
district which is where all your science
buildings will be housed you know it's
not like older Sims where you can just
you'll unlock a certain you'll learn a
certain technology you'll be able to
build a university in your city tile now
you actually have to have that univer at
the campus tile so you can have a
university you can have like all your
astronomy towers and whatnot if you put
those next to mountains you'll get
bonuses but then if you put like an
aqueduct next to a river but also
adjacent to it like a jungle for
instance you'll get like these bonuses
so my cities were unfolding in a way
that I wasn't considering just those
first hundred fifty turns so like I was
like intern like three hundred fifty or
something and looked back was like if I
had just put this aqueduct up farther up
the river would again the adjacency
bonus from this other city that I had so
it really made me also consider how to
attack cities and how to defend them
like I said I was a Vikings I was going
from very like a amphibious assault kind
of thing like using their bonuses along
the coast like near other cities and
then I knew this one city I like my
advisors told me that they're really far
ahead of me in technology I think it was
a it might've been the Romans and so I
saw I saw they had a campus districts I
think that's the first one I'm gonna go
for at least I'm going to you know if
not pillage and raise it I'm going to at
least lay siege to it and try to like
halt their science production so it
really made you think about if you're
not just going to go destroy a
civilization if you're militarily
inclined maybe you can just like hobble
their main advantage so that's was a
really cool way of like you know I
wasn't just attacking a city tile and
you might just destroy the university
and right in the process I have heard
that knowledge is power so exactly so I
was like I might as well just destroy
the Romans knowledge and then remove
their power so it worked out it was a it
this unstack cities in the active
research and like the leader agenda is
all kind of coalesced in the way that
made the entire playthrough really
engaging engaging being kind of a cliche
word but I really was constantly
thinking rather than just kind of going
through the motions and those mid game
turns gotcha so based on this
playthrough do you think that other
future playthroughs will be different I
mean is there clearly kind of some
variety that could impact how the game
plays each time through because I know
certain players will kind of find their
style and just lay into this one
particular way of playing the game
you think that this is going to
challenge those types of players you
think people are gonna be kind of forced
to employ different strategies and play
the game in different ways I think so
yeah like this is the first time I've
played past like a hundred fifty turns
and from what I've played it kind of
made it like idealistically it will
because I you know the acts of research
pulled me in a few different directions
I didn't plan I was going like you know
bronze workin like steel and then like
trying to get my navy like battleships
going because like the Vikings again are
very like uh naval the like a
civilization and the entire time I was
kind of I would you know build a quarry
and then they would unlock masonry for
me and I'd be like I'd even planned that
but now I kind of want to go down that
part of the tree but I also just want to
keep going down like building my army up
and then giving them better supplies
better equipment but then something else
would unlock and I would get a new
luxury resource and near my city like
[ __ ] that would really help me if I want
to build like a market and like really
establish an economy but then I would
have to kept like making me rethink
everything and I probably could have won
faster if I did go down like another
route I was actually kind of hard-headed
but it challenged me in my plan much
more than other sibs have so I want to
play another playthrough I almost want
to play the Vikings again to see how
different unfolds based on the map and
where I put my city tiles and what the
active research does to pull me in one
way or the other any other big takeaways
from this first full playthrough it's
promising um I'm like being a huge SIF
and I probably played like five hundred
something hours into five since it
released and you know it's a team that
made the expansions for five that are
making they're like the first time there
as a team making their first full game
so I'm really excited to see what kind
of like things they've done to tweak the
SIF formula in minor ways there's a ton
of minor additions they've done that
like aren't just like on stacking cities
or active research or you know like the
hidden agendas it really just feels like
it might be something fresh that the
franchise needs I guess we'll find out
when it releases obviously but as of now
I'm I'm really excited cool well I know
that we have a little bit more sieve
coverage planned before the game is out
but until then just stay tuned to
Gamescom for everything Civ and
everything video games
cool
[Music]